[موسيقى]
بحيث جبل الشرقيه مدينه نيالا يسكن الفاتح
حسين تقني العيون الذي حولته المعارك بين
الجيش والدعم السريع هنا بجنوب دارفور الى
جراح يستخرج المغذوفات والرصاصه من اجساد
المصابين جراء المعارك
في واحده انضرب في العين
وقاموا لقيت المخزون موجود في الجفن فقمت
انا زلت المخزون من الجن بكل براعه يعني
الحمد لله رب العالمين توفيق من ربنا وبعد
ذلك الناس يعني قاعد في العياده بتاعته
شغال
وكل المستشفيات مقفله وكل العيادات مقفله
يعني والضرب كان كثير جدا جدا وكثيف
والناس بقت بعدلك
للعياده بامكانياتهم محدوده في هذه
العياده الصغيره ازرق الفاتح اكثر من
ثلاثين عمليه ناجحه يستند فيها على خبره
اكتسبها من دراسه اسعاف حالات الكوارث
الطبيعيه والحروب في وقت سابق بعد طبعا
الناس بقت تشيل الناس تجيب المساله
ويقولون
سريع وكده وكلهم يعني اسعفناهم ولا
بعدك
السكان هنا يمتدحون ما يقوم به من خدمه
انسانيه وكيف انه اصبح طوق نجاه للعديد
ممن طالتهم المغذوفات والرصاص والطائش
يعني
مرات بكون نايم زي ربع ساعه عشان ياخذ
راحته وناس يصحوا يعني يقول لنا
الامكانيات في الوقت الذي تعرضت فيه عشرات
المراكز باقليم دارفور للتخريب والدمر لا
سبيل للمصابين سوى التمسك بهذه الاجتهادات
الفرديه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات